[Music]
Natalie I'm dying to ask you a question
there's a theory out there there's a lot
of theories and they might be wrong we
might be right there's a theory that
I've heard from a lot of Game of Thrones
fans that Daenerys and The Sunday are
gonna get romantically involved have you
heard that theory that one that's a
popular theory actually people I wonder
why yeah I perform my understanding of
the books there is like this one moment
where she is on her way slavers Bay and
it's the first time since her husband
was a drug addict what's his name Joe
College I'll drag it right he he passed
away passes away it's the first time
that she's felt somewhat around since
his death and so she sort of you know
has a little uh may-maybe themselves.i
with herself okay all right all right
I'm here to guide us through this
conversation everybody this suddenly
feels like an encounter group doesn't it
yeah so she's she's aroused she's taking
care of business yeah she's she's
masturbating yes yes yes
it might Charlie was thinking of
something else yes if she's doing that
and then one of her handmaidens or fade
do to take over yeah
and it's a very small moment and I from
what I understand the character in the
book that does that is actually no
longer in the show right I said then
people were kind of like oh is that
gonna go to the sundae and I was like I
don't think so I'd be really surprised
if it did gentlemen take over yeah damn
let's move on next show we don't want to
say that that that couldn't happen
[Laughter]
you